mr. wears 500 pairs of socks to last a
week and they are scattered loose in his
drawer that's exactly what I do actually
each morning he gets up in full light
and chooses two socks at random find the
probability wears a matching pair and
then there's a whole bunch of sub
questions
so yeah I don't know if they've been
spying on me or something but this is
exactly what I do I don't know I think
I'm more than ten socks bet Sanford's
walkway so let's unpack this let's start
with the first one because it's the
easiest okay each morning he gets up
before that and chooses two socks at
random find the probability that he
wears a matching pair
but first morning probability I got a
whole budget everyone so I want to
describe this in a nice succinct but
unique way of a matching pair a match on
the first morning this is what I'm
interested okay now let's think about
this you've got to be careful about I
have to beat two socks right I've got to
pick two socks so there's this is a
multi-stage event if you want to think
about it that way right I got a pic of
first sock and then I've got a pink the
second sock does that make sense
okay now let's think about that first
salt let's think about the flow saw and
I'm just gonna write out over here I
don't have five colors so I'm going to
write that just as of different letters
okay so here are my 10 socks five pairs
right five different colors letters you
get the idea
now think about that first sock does it
matter which sock I pick like do I want
a particular song over any other word no
it doesn't matter right so the way I can
think about this is B this is all about
probability right probability and
probability is a fraction probably
always a fraction of something over
something what are the two things it's
favorable outcomes right favorable
outcomes the ones that you want over
sample space right okay so being that my
sample space clearly clearly that's ten
right but when I ask to you like which
sock do I want
well we don't care which one they're all
good at this point in time right so the
fatal outcomes is ten right so the first
thing I'm going to write is one now you
might think well why are you writing now
that's not gonna change the answer no
it's not but it's meaningful right as
you will see capturing all our meaning
in the working out that we do is
critical it starts off easy but it gets
tricky later on so I pick a sock okay
let's suppose this one right first sock
down and then I have to pick another one
and I want a match that's what I'm after
okay so two things have changed firstly
the sample space has changed right I
don't have ten socks anymore I have nine
right so that's reduced okay but also
now that I have one of the socks in
particular the favorable outcomes has
also changed right now that I've peaked
one the second one I only want this one
is the only one interested in yes okay
so far so good so the probability of
getting a match after that second sock
will be one times one
no ego there's a probability not so bad
right what's so hard about this question
well let's progress now they give you a
whole variety of different morning's to
make it easier to illustrate I'm just
gonna think about the next day 24 hours
past and now I'm thinking about being a
match the next day okay now keep in mind
this is quite separate to what happened
before I'm not thinking about a match
the first and second morning I would
have written first and second morning
here not two matches in a row just
forget about what happened the previous
day i mighta got a match I might not
have just interested in Tuesday ok
what's the probability of getting a
match now ok now who has an answer that
jumps out of them any any thoughts
whatever 9 ok 1 over 9 now how many
people agree with that you don't have to
provide an explanation I'm just
interested in who thinks that's a
positive answer
hands up straight I actually want to see
ok all right ok put your heads down
everyone who didn't put their hands up
just now I want you to raise your hand
for a second ok now I want you to keep
your hand off if the reason you don't
think it's 1 over 9 is because you think
it's something else do you think it's
something else for you you're you know
puttin down if you're just not sure but
keep your hand out if you think it's
something else
it can't be whatever no ok now anyone
who's still got their hands up because
by the way I have my hand up I think
this is weird this is very strange my
intuition is kicking in and saying
really anyone's got to hand up why you
put your hands down now but why you guys
who did have your hands up why do you
think this seems strange why do you
disagree he has to wash his socks okay
so what difference in that Bay
so yours okay all right so you're saying
this whole scenario this scenario is
with that replacement now hold on a
second before we leave off this who
thinks Elian is right who agrees this
situation is without replacement okay
hands down who thinks it is with
replacement sir okay hands that side
take it a few you don't know if that's
okay look at the question again look at
it carefully read it with me it's all in
the language is there anything in the
question that suggests to you it's gonna
be weird replacement all without I think
I think alien drugs
I think it's without a place I think the
key word he is he has five different
pairs of socks to lost the weight which
kind of implies by the time he gets to
Friday he's pulling the last two socks
out of the drawer up without replacement
I think is correct okay now hold on
let's keep pushing on that if it's
without replacement why is that a
problem
why is without replacement suggest you
this answer has a floor in it because
you would think but by the next morning
just like you know when we looked at the
first socket in the second saw the same
space would change right and we looked
at this yesterday we looked at the idea
dynamic probability where when one thing
depends on the previous thing then the
probably changes every time you would
think the second morning and the third
morning in every subsequent time
probabilities change right hmm so I
agree I agree that something seems
suspicious with this okay now the
question gives you a clue I write in the
beginner generators it says this
question and the necks are best done by
retelling the story of the experiment
now what happens is you go to the
answers okay and you look for this and
you find sure enough and I actually is
correct and then they give a bit of an
explanation and their explanation goes
like this they say they follow the
advice they say retell the story okay so
what they imagine is well you know how I
walk through this I said okay the first
morning I pick out this one
then I pick out this one right well
let's retell it
let's retell it like this okay it's
Monday morning I have ten socks in the
drawer okay but instead of getting out
Monday's socks on Monday morning I get
out Tuesday's socks on Monday morning
now what has changed and the answer is
nothing has changed I'm still gonna be
able to pick from ten slots it doesn't
matter which one I pick first and then
I'm still gonna get to pick out one that
matches out of the nine remaining okay
and so you know the second morning
actually and the third and the fourth
and the fifth they're all the same it's
all the same hmm now that's the answer
the textbook provides and it's true it
really works okay a knife is the answer
unambiguously as well no matter how you
took the question